you know many conservatives when we are
younger we will uh inevitably
experiment with libertarianism we dabble
in that uh
particular political ideology finding
that it appeals to our young
underdeveloped brains we start answering
every difficult social question with the
statement hey man just get the
government out of it we buy the book
atlas shrugged and tell everyone that we
read it even though we never even
glanced at the first page
these are the follies of youth and most
of us as we get older
we grow out of that phase and we feel
embarrassed by it the same way that
people who grew up in the 70s feel
embarrassed about having owned a pet
rock and the way people that grew up in
the 80s should feel embarrassed about
well everything that happened in that
decade but there are some grown adults
who
sadly
never graduate they never evolved they
never grow out of it
they end up looking as ridiculous and
awkward as a 50 year old man in a
backwards hat and that's what brings us
to
kim iverson who's a pundit of some kind
with a decent social media following who
seems to have attracted an audience of
of conservatives who believe that she's
on their side largely because she
doesn't like the vaccine and she says
nice things about donald trump those are
the two things i've noticed
apparently maybe there are other things
as well but those two things in
particular have attracted conservatives
to her that's why she has some kind of
audience i don't know how big it is and
that's all well and good
but it won't save her
now that she has torched her credibility
and revealed herself to be an amoral
idiot
and um every other kind of idiot too
kim responded to my tweet about dr scott
mosser the butcher who chops the breasts
off of adolescent girls
with this rebuttal this is what she said
their body their choice
if their parents or anyone is pressuring
them let them live with that and take it
up with them later it's none of our
business how others choose to live their
lives
yes her response to doctors removing the
body parts of physically healthy
children is
their body their choice
from here kim launched into a series of
tweets frantically searching for some
way to defend cosmetic double
mastectomies on teen girls she had just
she had thrown down the gauntlet
put down her marker climbed atop the
girls should have their breasts removed
hill and decided that
she would die on it that's what it took
reading through the tweets that followed
she she wrote um just going through a
series of these 16 year old girls get
nose jobs all the time where's your
outrage
shoulda woulda coulda again personal
choice i'm all for personal freedom live
and let live even if it leads to regret
if it's what they want to do it's what
they want to do
i'm not for controlling others because i
personally think it's morally wrong
you guys we're talking about boob jobs
let's keep things in perspective it's
literally none of your business if a
woman chooses to enlarge them or shrink
them from there she became even more inc
incoherent and desperate accusing me of
being a triggered snowflake for opposing
the mutilation of children which by the
way kim yes i am i am triggered by child
abuse i i admit i'm triggered by it i
find it quite upsetting even i i'm even
offended by i am offended
by the brutalization of children i am i
admit it
and then she started crying that she was
the victim of conservative cancel
culture because people were criticizing
her for her views
finally in one last blow to whatever
credibility she may have still been
clinging to
she asserted that not only can minors
consent to having their breasts removed
but they can also consent to sex she
posted quote
minors actually can consent to sex each
state has its own laws on this
later that night she posted a lengthy
twitter thread trying to defend her to
pray views in more detail writing quote
today proved it conservatives are no
different than woke liberals they just
choose different topics to be outraged
over and in their minds just like to
woke liberals this is different this is
immoral and must be stopped
my stance is clear i don't think the
government should interfere or be
involved in the consensual medical
decisions of others i don't know what
others are going through and i don't
believe that i nor the government should
be telling others what's best for them
yes who's to say what's best for anyone
if a girl's having her breasts chopped
off maybe that's best for if a kid is
playing in the street about to get hit
by a truck don't interfere after all
it's what he wants to do and it may be
best for him who are we to impose our
anti getting hit by truck views on that
child that would be rude that would be
oppressive
indeed if we were to prevent the child
from being killed in traffic we'd be no
better than woke leftists
constantly trying to impose our
subjective views on others what are you
some kind of snowflake outrage about
kids getting hit by cars you snowflake
cancel culture you're trying to cancel
people who hit who who hit children with
their cars stop cancelling them
great points kim
you have the moral insight of a lizard
and you should be quite proud
now
there's too much nonsense here to handle
but we'll we'll do our best to pick
through it
first of all to clarify our terms here
top surgery quote unquote is a double
mastectomy
a double mastectomy is not a boob job
the breasts are not being enlarged nor
are they being reduced they're being
removed
the breast tissue the mammary glands all
of it is being cut off
the procedure unlike breast implants
which i also would oppose for children
because i'm not a disgusting creep
but unlike implants a mastectomy is not
reversible a person who has this
procedure and regrets it as many do and
many many more will
as this current crop of children become
adults
they they can for a large fee try to
reconstruct some approximation of
something that looks like female breasts
but they will never have female breasts
ever again they'll never be able to
nurse their children
all of that is gone forever based on a
choice they made when they were
adolescents
but can they make a choice like that as
a child
that's the question kim says they can
and she cites the fact that the age of
consent in some states is 16. now the
problem with this approach is that first
of all children are being subjected to
medical and surgical gender transitions
much younger than 16. dr scott mosser is
doing it at 14 at 13. he would do it at
12. he would do it at any age
second the age of consent in california
is 18. yet dr scott mosser is operating
in california
on on girls who allegedly consent to
having their breasts removed at 16 or
younger
third even if the age of consent is 16
in some states like in vermont i think
it's 16 for example
um
does that mean that it's actually
morally right automatically i mean is it
the age of consent in in
vermont is 16. so is it okay for a 50
year old man to have sex with a 16 year
old in that state
just because that's what it says on
paper
what would you say about such a man kim
what if he had a 16 year old daughter
you'd be okay with her date dating a 50
year old
because oh she can do what she wants and
age of consent
actually don't answer that question
don't tell me how you feel about it
because i don't want to know
now this may come as a shock to you kim
but
did you know
did you know this
uh and again maybe make sure you're
sitting down for this part this is this
is gonna surprise you
laws
can be wrong
did you know that there are times when
laws allow things that they shouldn't
allow
the law allowed slavery at one time
the law has allowed many terrible things
right now the law in many states allows
yes it does
doctors to castrate and butcher children
that's true
but the law is wrong
and we know that it's wrong because no
matter what any politician wrote onto a
piece of paper certain scientific and
moral truths remain one of those truths
is that a child does not have a fully
developed brain that's a fact she's not
capable of making fully informed
decisions she's not capable of thinking
through the consequences of her actions
she does not she's not capable of it she
does not have the maturity and
competence or or
brain chemistry required to be entrusted
with permanent life-altering decisions
this is a fact confirmed by neurology
and also by the experience of every
adult human who has ever lived on earth
because we've all been 16 at one time
and so we know these things
what this means is that it's not
possible for a child to make a
consensual medical decision as you say
the statement makes no sense
they cannot consent to what they do not
understand
now there are moral truths too
one of those moral truths is that it is
wrong to harm a child
that is wrong to do
it doesn't matter what the law says it
doesn't matter what the law allows
doesn't even matter what the child says
it is wrong to harm a child causing
permanent severe physical damage
is the worst kind of physical harm
possible short of outright murder
now if you don't think that we can make
moral determinations like this then i
mean what do you support should we
repeal all of the child abuse laws in
the country
maybe you would support that
the libertarian mind virus seems to be
terminal in your case so there's no
telling how far you would go
now you say that conservatives are no
different than woke liberals because we
declare this is different this is
immoral it must be stopped
but but
what you fail to understand kim is that
some things are different from other
things not all things are the same
some things are there are things that
are one thing and then you have
something else that's different from
that thing
some things actually are immoral and
really must be stopped
just because woke liberals make moral
claims and demand that certain things be
stopped
that doesn't mean that all moral claims
are automatically wrong and that nothing
at all should be stopped
the problem with the woke liberal is not
that he condemns certain behavior
it's that he is wrong about what he
condemns
he is morally confused
and so are you and in that way you are
like the woke liberal which is why both
of you find yourselves defending the
most grotesque form of child abuse the
world has ever seen
you are right about one thing though
i do practice my own form of cancer
culture
that's what this segment is all about
and it's why you have found yourself in
it and it's also why you today are
unfortunately canceled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
that wall show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this youtube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts